- [Narrator] How to stay motivated.
When you look at people
who are successful,
you will find that they aren't the people
who are motivated,
but have consistency in their motivation.
Being an entrepreneur
sucks a lot of the time.
It's hard to stay motivated.
You might have a fantastic day,
be on top of the world,
and then the next morning,
wake up and find you're
starting from scratch.
You're doing some thing different,
something new,
something powerful.
And it takes time to make it happen.
You might have a little man in your life
telling you all the reasons why
you're not going to be successful.
You might not be seeing
any growth or momentum
as you struggle to find your way.
You might even be thinking of going back
to get a job and do the safe thing
to support your family.
Man, it's hard trying to stay motivated
as an entrepreneur,
but you know what helps?
Feeling like you're doing
something important.
That's what people
really want out of life.
That's probably what you
hated about your last job.
You wanted to wake up and feel like
the work you are doing was important.
When you get that feeling,
you're more likely to stay motivated,
and that comes from finding your one word
and applying it to make a positive impact
on the world.